this has bigger these are pathetic  feeble excuses can we dare take it that  there are no circumstances that he will  debate me head-to-head between now in  the general election we've had four  years of debate so we found out he's got  no policies he's got no plan he's got no  team he's got no clue of running the  country but the truth mr. speaker is  this labor are now saying they cannot  win the election here is the leaflet  they put out in Scotland I think the SMP  might be interested in this at the  general election we need to stop the  Tories being the largest party they're  not trying to win they're just trying to  crawl through the gates of Downing  Street on the coattails of the SMP what  he's going to do is prove that he's not  a chicken and ruled that out